[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
J'ai vu le grand-père la dernière fois dans le
2000 et le corps est comme une énorme baleine
il n'a pas d'écailles et ressemble à une peau d'éléphant
au-dessus du gris foncé et comme
il atteignait le ventre plus clairement et
Ils ont des nageoires et ils ont une très longue queue.
Fini qui joue Timon
ils ont un cou très haut
et la petite tête et je calcule plus ou
moins d'environ 12 mètres
énorme
[Musique]
quand je l'ai bien vu avec la longue vue
J'ai cherché rapidement dans l'encyclopédie pour voir
Ce n'est pas vrai les dessins que j'ai de
l'encyclopédie alors j'ai dit oh tu es un
plétosaure
[Musique]
tout le monde a dit le monstre du lac
Pourquoi monstre? Alors je dis que c'est un
grand-père un animal préhistorique et depuis
Alors ils s'appellent Nahuelito Nahuel el
lac
et a ajouté le grand-père
[Musique]
à la contemplation
C'est arrivé à cinq kilomètres d'ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les mesures estimées
ils mesuraient environ 22 25 mètres
long sur son dos, il avait deux hémisphères et
ces hémisphères avaient une très
particulier qu'il était vert
quand il est parti il ​​a fait beaucoup de vagues sur la côte
[Musique]
fait de carburant
nous étions environ un groupe de 20
des gens qui, lorsqu'ils ont vu l'ampleur
ils ont été très surpris
est resté dans nos yeux
environ 20 minutes une demi-heure
C'était une coïncidence avec laquelle je n'ai pas été
lui parce que je l'ai beaucoup accompagné
J'ai suivi les voyages qu'il a fait
il avait presque neuf dix ans et quand il
est venu à la maison pour discuter de ce qui était
c'est arrivé je disais comment ai-je pu le rater
J'ai aussi eu le sentiment de peur
les temps suivants qui l'accompagne à
il
dans le bateau bon d'être toujours
attentif aux couleurs des mouvements
qui surgissait au fur et à mesure qu'on sillonnait
le lac
[Musique]
On disait que sur l'île on voit ici
derrière le fond il y avait des pumas
c'est pourquoi ils l'ont nommée l'île de Los tigres
ou l'île aux lions
quand on parle de nahualito on est
Parle toujours de quelque chose d'inconnu
beaucoup croyaient qu'il y avait un plésiosaure
dans ce lieu et c'est
très difficile
les voisins parlent de nahualito avec
beaucoup d'amour ils parlent
je n'ai pas eu l'occasion de voir
grand-père comme certaines personnes
ils prétendent l'avoir vu j'ai vu des choses
que je ne peux pas savoir s'ils le sont vraiment
événements physiques qui surviennent
une cause de réaction chimique sous
surface sûrement pas n'a pas été ni
un animal, loin de là c'est un lac
que tu as un mystère et que j'ai le
la chance de vivre au bord du lac
nahuel huapi je vois toute la nuit
choses intéressantes
luminescences dans le lac
les choses se voient
étrange disons
La Patagonie à travers les années a
transformé en un lieu
de beaucoup de magie et de beaucoup de mystère
premières histoires connues
Ils parlent d'un lieu plein de mystères
plein de mort même sur les cartes
de l'antiquité figuré comme le pays
du diable San Carlos de Bariloche était
à ses débuts
une région de peuplement
nomades des communautés nomades du
Tehuelches il y a des milliers d'années et avec le
le temps s'est transformé en
petite ville qui était une colonie
L'élevage agricole au fil du temps
le tourisme a marqué l'orientation économique de la
ville
et suis venu à ce qui est à ce que je suis
Bref, c'est un endroit comme un village de
montagne dont je suis fier
vivre
étoilé
quand je suis arrivé il y a environ 50 ans
Bariloche n'existait pas ici, c'était un village
tout n'était pas explosé il n'y avait pas d'égout
il n'y avait pas de lumière ou je pensais au téléphone ou
câbler rien
[Musique]
pour la première fois
Je dois supposer que c'était en 1910 le deuxième
le temps plus tard était en 1936
et la quatrième fois en 1957 puis en 1986
et les dernières apparitions en 2006 dans le
moment où l'on parle d'un
Précieux saur qui s'est éteint il y a 65 ans
des millions d'années
C'est un peu difficile, ils vont le prendre comme
une chose très folle
et je n'étais pas le seul à l'avoir vu car deux
plus de gens qui l'ont vu mais pas
Je voulais ne rien dire parce qu'ici quand tu
vous voyez quelque chose d'extraordinaire que les gens disent
pris trop
nous allons dire que le prix saury de
Grand-père a donné à cet endroit un
résonance osseuse avec mon grand-père
Bariloche a grandi avant de vivre autrement
façon dont ils vivaient en pêchant dans le lac de
les récoltes en changement maintenant Bariloche
vit d'un tourisme autrefois
grand-père a été installé dans l'esprit
de personnes de nombreuses personnes de
Buenos Aires beaucoup de touristes beaucoup de monde
d'autres parties du monde voulaient venir
voyons ce monstre
[Musique]
les mapuche
cuir
les anciens colons les mapuches qui
Ils ont peuplé toute cette région et sont toujours
voler, ils avaient une légende très
particulier que c'était la légende du cuir
qu'ils voyaient le cuir comme du cuir
flottant dans le lac qui a emporté
les animaux
grâce à cela, il est devenu populaire
la relation entre le monstre a commencé
en l'an 1910 où la première fois un
monsieur nommé george garrett
qui était le premier en fait
voyant
au monstre lui-même qu'il
Il a dit qu'il avait vu une bosse flotter dans
le lac de sept mètres de long
cette nouvelle est venue
vite et bien ils ont commencé à parler
des animaux que l'on pourrait trouver
des États-Unis cela dit Oui
nous avons toujours dit que
La Patagonie peut avoir des anti-animaux
déluges
Et bien sûr qui devait apparaître
j'ai dit que je l'avais vu martin sheffield
chercheur d'or nord-américain typique et
conduire un personnage de ceux qu'il n'est pas
VRAI
[Musique]
de Buenos Aires
qui était à l'époque directeur de
Zoo de Buenos Aires avec les armés
une expédition pour venir ici et
être capable de capturer le monstre du lac pour
cours N'a capturé aucun monstre
il n'y avait rien que je t'ai dit là-dedans
moment, il a donné deux mille pesos forts à
Martin à l'époque dont je parle
1922 environ
pour avoir fait tout ce déplacement pour
lui avoir parlé du monstre et du reste et
il a gardé ces 2000 pesos
[Musique]
Journalistes correspondants du Carnaval
les habitants envoient les nouvelles de Buenos Aires
la capture du plésiosaure acculé
attrapé
c'est le Carnaval
C'est un masque de carnaval
C'est la plus grosse blague jamais faite.
cette région pendant plus d'un siècle et a été
pour ces carnavals qui flottent avec
forme de plésiosaure apparue par
première fois en centre ville
marchant dans la rue Mitre et de
là la légende ou le mythe du grand-père
était en vigueur et avait une présence dans
patrimoine traditionnel ou culturel de la
Ville de Bariloche
dans les premiers carnavals de Bariloche
l'un des éléments qui dominaient
scène dans la rue la plus éthique de
Bariloche le seul à cette époque était
Figurine Preciosaurus de Clemente
Onelli ou Martin Sheffield sont apparus
cet énorme personnage défilant à travers le
rues et ainsi ce mythe a été créé
vérité ou réalité qui est notre célèbre
et cher nahuelito, pourquoi commencez-vous à
aime un personnage que tu ne connais pas
mais
est devenu une riche histoire pour
cette région et dans un élément de
promotion du tourisme Comme personne n'avait
suspecté l'arrivée du chemin de fer
plus les légendes du monstre du lac
Nahuel Huapi plus tout le reste fait
un contingent de touristes
approche de la zone j'en dis même plus
apprendre à connaître la région parce que se rendre à
Bariloche à cette époque n'était pas très facile
à cette époque les crayons pour
l'écriture était faite de bois avec une feuille
plus tard, ils n'en ont pas fait qui avaient
la petite tête du plésiosaure et tous les
les enfants des écoles voulaient en avoir un
stylo plésiosaure
il y avait des cigarettes de marque plésiosaure
et même un tango que je vous montre ici
le plésiosaure
[Musique]
l'écharpe
et les nouvelles sortent plus de touristes aperçus
le phénomène de nahuel huapi nouveau
témoignages sur une vision étrange de ce
il y a des notes et des notes le papy 2 a
voisin un cher voisin
il l'a appelé grand-père, il n'a pas cherché
quel était le nom de mon grand-père
première apparition à l'été 1994
alors notez si vous remarquez un autre étranger
observation au lac nahuel huapi
il y a eu un boom des apparitions entre les années 70
et le 80 pour moi tout ce genre de
les animaux existent
[Musique]
et je ne vais pas à votre preuve scientifique
Parce que si je dois passer des tests
scientifique je dois dire non
n'existe pas
Michelangelo Rossi réaliste
[Musique]
Je développe un projet
flamme sous traitement de surface
principalement sur la question de
mythe du grand-père au lac nahuel
huapi de Patagonie ce projet
a précisément l'intention de mettre le
spectateur sous-marin qui a toujours
on voit tous les jours ce qu'on vit ici
à San Carlos de Bariloche nous sommes
filmer à plusieurs mètres
profondeur et nous trouvons des choses
vraiment intéressant ce lac a un
profondeur qu'il y a de nombreuses années était
enregistré 500 mètres mais
les études les plus récentes montrent que
il peut y avoir plus de 800 places presque
1000 mètres
les observations des grands-parents ont
avait
historiquement trois lieux où
vu plus il y a un endroit appelé la
zone de 500 mètres
il est né un bras qui s'appelle le bras
tristesse qui est l'un des endroits où
plus de fois a-t-il vu grand-père
[Musique]
Grand-père est tout un phénomène pour le
habitants de cette région et bien plus encore
même pour les Visiteurs je n'en avais pas
expérience
concernant un spectacle ou quelque chose qui est
ressemble à un mouvement étrange dans le
lac nahuel huapi malgré avoir
né à Bariloche Oui j'avais pour moi
profession et parce que j'ai pris de nombreuses notes
histoire de voisins qui prétendent avoir
vu ce que nous définissons aujourd'hui comme un
grand-père
avec des proches d'un important
homme d'affaires décédé dans l'année
Il y avait quatre trois hommes d'affaires et un
directeur de banque
familles connues d'ici à Bariloche
C'était un jour comme aujourd'hui le fameux calme
chicha il n'y avait pas de houle dans le lac nahuel
huapi étaient dans un bateau très sûr
et tout d'un coup la nouvelle était
qu'ils ont disparu le bateau a été laissé
retour à la cloche était en panne
quatre personnes sont apparues trois corps
l'autre est toujours porté disparu et était un
vrai inconnu pourquoi ils étaient
pêcher parce qu'ils étaient vieux parce que
ils n'ont pas roulé à grande vitesse dans le
bateau parce qu'il n'y avait pas de vent alors
tout cela est comme se nourrir ou
renvoie la possibilité que
en effet dans le lac nahuel huapi
quelque chose existe qu'il y a quelque chose qui existe encore
nous ne savons pas
Je pense que grand-père est un mythe pour
certains est une réalité si cela se produit déjà
être à nous
Si ce n'est pas le cas, nous félicitons ceux qui
Ils ont raconté une légende un conte
fiction qui a déjà atteint les plans
télévision internationale de temps en temps
quand il montre une histoire de certains
voisin la radio fait pareil et quoi
ils ont fortement pris ce sont les
dessinateurs ou dessinateurs
pouvez-vous imaginer mon grand-père comme
figure centrale et mascotte de ce
ville tous les cinq ans Nous parlons
fortement de lui
environ dans cinq ans, vous pouvez avoir un
histoires d'apparitions histoires qui disent
après avoir vu mon grand-père puis revenir
comme un profond silence où personne
parle jusqu'à ce qu'il se relève par
une autre histoire populaire la figure de ce
petit animal
[Musique]
Je n'ai pas personnellement vu mon grand-père
si j'ai vu deux ou trois films
m'a vraiment fait réfléchir
assez parlé de son existence.
J'aimerais bien le voir s'il existe Y
Oui, je fais attention à ceux qui
ils disent l'avoir vu parce que généralement
les yeux ne mentent pas et ajoutèrent qu'à la
tradition à un peu d'histoire
de sa présence de son existence il y a
rendre hommage à ceux qui le font
ils disent qu'ils existent papy
les observations de grand-père toujours
ont été faites à l'époque où dans le lac
c'est très calme qu'il semble que c'était
comme on dit ici repassé comme si c'était
une huile à l'époque
se peut voir
les mouvements internes peuvent être vus
les mouvements de l'eau et vous pouvez voir
émergent alors que les reins du rivage ont
vu ont vu beaucoup ont sorti
les photos ont été filmées
mais ils ne se démarquent pas trop pour ça
le lac doit être très calme
Je pense
que puisqu'il n'y avait pas de vagues parce que la houle
renouvelle l'oxygène dans l'eau
au lieu de cela, le lac était encore immobile
toujours aussi repassant
Et sûrement ils ont fait surface
s'oxygéner pour
sentir l'oxygène n'a pas semblé froid ou
quelque chose comme ça. C'était vraiment très long.
étouffant et ils sont sortis
protégés par l'île ils ne sont pas sortis
ouvertement
[Musique]
de toutes les observations certaines
terrain d'entente sur tout
quand les gens disent ça
apparaît comme s'il s'agissait de l'arrière d'un
baleine avec un bruit très fort
à plusieurs endroits, c'est courant
même avec une différence d'histoire de
beaucoup d'années
et il y a des histoires
très fort aussi où
assurer que cette longe qui a émergé de la
Lago a eu une influence sur certains
accidents survenus dans le lac
avec des bateaux et avec des pêcheurs avec
familles qui naviguaient pas le
la plupart des vidéos semblent montrer
quelque chose mais ce n'est rien j'en ai vu beaucoup
des choses qui sont des troncs j'ai même vu
images de quelques animaux
ils appellent ça ils sont comme de grosses loutres
J'ai vu des vagues ce qu'on appelle parfois les
fameuse vague unique quand le lac est très
repassage il y a des courants internes qui
Ils soulèvent une vague et puis c'est fini
il y a des vidéos qui ont vraiment
surpris et je ne peux pas dire ce que c'est mais
Ce n'est ni une bûche flottante ni des bullyines
nager ni la seule vague
La Patagonie a toujours été très dure depuis
du début à la fin et bien plus encore
dur est au bout du monde où
ils appellent la fin du monde pas à ushuaia
terre de feu les légendes
Patagonie, par exemple, que vous avez le
cité des Césars tu as la légende
Eh bien, vous avez une infinité de cuir
choses qui font de la Patagonie un endroit
Si tu veux dire un peu enchanté là
différentes cultures dont si l'on
apprendre
Vous avez la richesse totale avant tout
culture du peuple de la terre pas que
les premiers étaient les initiateurs
qui a d'abord peuplé la Patagonie en
En fait, il existe des documents datant d'il y a 17 000 ans.
ans ces monstres que tu vois ici
viennent souvent de la tradition dans
la tradition se transmet oralement
disons non
La Patagonie est magnifique, il y avait déjà
dit Darwin lors de son voyage ici en
1833 est un musée géant est un lieu
où les fossiles abondent
Un plésiosaure est un animal qui a
long cou a quatre nageoires deux
avant et deux arrière et une queue
ils étaient purement des animaux aquatiques voir un
plésiosaure aujourd'hui dans un lac, c'est comme
voir un homme d'un million d'années
marcher dans la rue est techniquement
impossible il y a 65 millions d'années
Les prix des sauriens disparaissent et c'est
impossible qu'elles existent aujourd'hui
cela ne signifie pas que la nature
nous en avons réservé
surprendre
ils ont peut-être encore survécu
certains animaux comme le cœlacanthe
exemple que c'est un poisson qui a été trouvé dans
L'Inde existe depuis environ 60 ans.
pensé éteint il y a 65 millions d'années
années
et que les poissons formaient des hybrides hybrides
hybrides jusqu'à la flèche d'aujourd'hui
Je suppose que si ce poisson qui est
Il aurait dû disparaître il y a 65 ans
des millions d'années et ce n'est pas le cas parce que ce n'est pas le cas
aurait pu survivre et faire
a vécu un précieux il y a un travail
faite par des scientifiques de
Université du Sud de l'Argentine
où ils ont découvert que le célèbre
reins que l'on voit naviguer sur l'eau
Ce sont des bulles de gaz sortant d'un
défaut qu'il y a dans le lac nahuel huapi
qu'ils forment
comme si c'était le dos d'un plésiosaure
qui navigue dans ces bulles de gaz
sont produits parce que nous sommes
dans un bassin pétrolier nous
Nous avons une culture très, très technologique.
la technologie partout où il n'y en a pas
mal bien sûr c'est bien mais
beaucoup d'entre nous n'oublient pas
de ce qu'est la terre de ce que
la terre nous donne ce que la terre nous donne
enseigner donc nous ne pouvons pas
Accepter
Comment puis-je vous dire la croyance que
il peut y avoir un monstre dans un lac
comment une telle chose peut-elle exister
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que le lac nahuel huapi
a des connexions avec l'océan Pacifique
c'est pourquoi ils disent que grand-père viendrait
de l'océan Pacifique à ici, mais que
c'est impossible aussi disent les chiliens
que cet animal est vu dans le Pacifique
Maintenant, comment est-il arrivé ici? Je pense que le
La cordillère n'est pas une masse mais il y a
sous terre parce que sinon comment peut-il être
Que le lac est toujours au même
hauteur car avec la pluie ça ne pousse pas
et l'océan Pacifique était ici et le
nahuel huapi ici sur le web guapi
aurait de l'eau salée oui et si j'allais au
inverser que je le tourne à pied c'est plus haut
que le pacifique
couleraient les eaux du nahuel huapi
dans le Pacifique et non dans l'Atlantique et si
étaient tous les deux au même niveau, il y aurait
Je devrais avoir une très grande grotte
[Musique]
le sentiment que j'ai de vivre ici est
de la liberté de l'air pur sur l'ensemble
silence
et tôt le matin j'entends le
des oiseaux
et j'ai un shell qui est un est un
le bateau va bien gros gris qui s'arrête
jusqu'au poteau et nous avons un
conversation
j'ai une connexion
très fort avec la nature
en général
autant qu'il s'agit d'arbres plantes et
les animaux
dans les cultures indigènes sont très
différents de nos cultures, ils
ils respectent la terre ils respectent leur
les traditions respectent leurs citations
ses monstres ses êtres mythologiques
ils les respectent car cela fait partie de leur
la vie sur terre en fait partie
ils l'appellent monstre
De quel droit avons-nous ?
Trouvons des animaux qui ne sont pas les mêmes
que ce que nous savons que je ne sais pas
ressemble à un cheval ou une abeille ou un
chien
pourquoi devons-nous aller appeler le
monstres
quand il est apparu
là-bas sur l'île ils étaient beaucoup plus gros que moi
ça devait être la femelle et deux autres
petits
ils jouaient là-bas, c'est pourquoi ils
éclaboussant comme qui dit non que c'est
maman avec les garçons sur la plage
et ceci et c'est pourquoi je pouvais les voir tous les
corps qui ne sont pas terrestres
ils ont des nageoires quatre nageoires j'ai adoré
ce n'est pas vrai qu'ils étaient
libre et en cela
celui que je supposais était la femelle
s'arrêta brusquement et regarda du côté de la
Le lac et les bateaux du Yacht Club sont venus
Alors j'ai commencé à crier ici
[Musique]
une folle
s'ils m'ont écouté ou s'ils ne m'ont pas écouté
question qu'ils m'ont fait disparaître
sous l'eau
nous n'allons pas
étude
une créature comme vous dites est
nageant dedans nous allons enquêter
voir ce que c'est parce que c'est ici
on passe directement avec un arbono avec un
bombe que nous devons détruire
au lieu de cela, les gens avant notre
les ancêtres n'ont pas fait ça
qu'il existe des circonstances d'un
observation ou une photographie qui
soi-disant il peut être pris
occasionnellement mais preuve scientifique
scientifique non pas parce que
scientifiques
très difficile de croire qu'un animal de cette
caractéristiques d'une bête de ceux
les caractéristiques peuvent avoir survécu
Trop de ces changements climatiques et
le reste
chaque légende vient d'une réalité
d'abord il y a la réalité ensuite
devient une légende et puis
déjà devenu un mythe
l'une des versions qui affirment que le
grand-père n'existe pas
Je le tire des expériences d'un
ancien capitaine de la marine décédé aujourd'hui
s'appelait Don Fernando Galiani du
1930 quand il a commencé à naviguer
au lac nahuel huapi
J'ai soutenu que la présence de mon grand-père
n'était ni plus ni moins que ce qu'il
appelée la vague morte
cette théorie que j'avais comme
valide m'a fait
réfléchir à la possibilité que
vraiment l'animal
existé parce qu'un jour un ami descendait
la mienne descendant le clocher a vu un
mouvement bizarre dans le lac plus ou moins
entre le mouvement et la chaise environ deux
kilomètres
et il a pointé son appareil photo et l'a apporté avec
le zoom et c'était un corps qui était
en mouvement
qui remonte à la surface
formant un cercle une courbe dans
en fait très proche de la côte du bras
clocher presque en surface car le
la couleur du corps était plus ou moins
gris clair grisâtre dans ma mémoire et
revient toujours en courbe pour s'enfoncer dans le
l'eau et ceux-ci ont vraiment disparu
images
ils nous ont fait penser que peut-être
aucun animal vivant se trouvait dans
profondeurs dans nahuel huapi parce que
Je le répète un coffre ne monte pas en courbe
à la surface et retomber
une trajectoire planifiée mais qui
vraiment eu la vie et devrait être
assez grand ceux d'entre nous qui étaient plus
sceptique à l'idée de commencer sa vie dans le
présence de mon grand-père la vérité que
à ce moment nous lui avons donné le doute de pourquoi
au moins il y avait quelque chose sous le lac
mais je ne savais pas très bien
[Musique]
de la télévision nationale
Je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de similaire
demander à une raie je pense qu'il y a
un couple ou
un individu qui est
ceci et qu'il peut vivre tranquillement ou
être soutenu du lac calmement
J'ai été surpris de voir quelque chose
flottant dans le lac, c'était comme un
ballon noir qui arrive à toute vitesse
de la péninsule de San Pedro
du fond de la Cordillère
Je suis allé chercher la longue vue pour
mieux se concentrer
et quand
Je me concentre sur la longue vue, je vois que cette chose
le noir qui flottait n'était pas un ballon ordinaire
ni un sous-marin comme je le pensais
parce qu'il avait un très long cou
avec la tête haute pour dire que je pensais que
c'était le périscope et quand j'ai vu tous les
corps
J'ai rapidement cherché une feuille pour le dessiner et
J'ai appelé la radio pour dire oui pour
S'il vous plaît regardez parce que je ne voulais pas être le
unique que j'ai vu un tel animal
J'ai un appareil photo, des photos mais je n'avais pas
rouleau
pas vrai et
stetosaurus ne m'a pas prévenu car
téléphone quand il est venu
peut-être qu'il est venu beaucoup plus de fois que moi
Je ne pouvais pas le voir Pas à partir de la date à laquelle il est venu
les deux fois les trois fois je l'ai vu
le lac était repassé il n'y avait pas
le temps était très oppressant
pour moi il se nourrit d'algues tu ne lui donnes pas
ni la bouche pour manger une personne
Si jamais ça arrivait
manger un être humain serait mort
empoisonné
parce que nous sommes si mauvais
nous exsudons tellement de mal que cela aurait
poison mort mon pauvre papy
[Musique]
Prenons en compte un détail
intéressant les lacs ce ne sont pas des lacs
très anciennes leur antiquité sont rondes entre
un million et demi d'années
à peu près
entre l'espace de 65 millions d'années
il y a un million et demi où il vivait
grand-père si le lac n'existait pas le
grand-père ne pouvait pas exister
ces animaux étaient de l'eau
techniquement chaud car ceux du
Le système jurassique et crétacé avait des mers
avec des eaux un peu plus chaudes Mais
C'est peut-être parce qu'on l'observe plus dans
été qu'en hiver en hiver ici
Il fait très froid et ça ne donne pas grand-chose à
se tenir au bord du lac pour regarder pour voir
ce qui se passe et il y a beaucoup
vent l'eau est plus en mouvement
contrairement à l'été que l'eau
c'est plus encore et peut-être que ça viendra
Ils voient certaines choses mais ce n'est pas
indicatif de dire qu'en été
viens plus qu'en hiver je pourrais te dire
en été les bulles de gaz sont
plus soluble et monte avec beaucoup plus
facilité qu'en hiver Apparemment
il y aurait des animaux rares dans différents
endroits dans le monde personne vraiment
scie
nous n'avons pas non plus vu Dieu et cru en Dieu
ce n'est pas vrai
[Musique]
J'ai une théorie pour moi il y a des tortues
des géants dans ce lac les scientifiques
Ils disent qu'il n'y a pas, j'ai eu des tortues
avec mon fils dans la main des tortues
grands
tortues dans ce lac
Disons que je pense qu'il y a peut-être eu un
déformation d'une sorte de tortue
C'est une zone de tortues d'autrefois
un long moment
Espérons que la recherche à travers cela
le travail audiovisuel me donne raison mais
nous voulons ce qui est mais quelque chose est
certains disent qu'il y a une tortue
géant mais la tortue est un animal est
un reptile et dans les eaux froides je ne pense pas
que je pourrais marcher longtemps car dans
le milieu de l'hiver gèlerait dans le
les reptiles ont besoin de chaleur pour vivre
eau froide
à cette époque à cette époque où nous sommes
vivant tout ce que je te cache dans le
enquête sur les ovnis tout est scellé
Intégration cryptologique secrète lo
même
Donc les gens n'ont pas de moyens comme
pour pouvoir rechercher nous en savons plus sur
espace que ce que nous avons ici
[Musique]
il y a des zones au Congo au Congo Belge
en Afrique qui sont encore inexplorables
dans la jungle brésilienne ils suivent
découvrir les tribus indigènes que nous sommes
vivre dans un monde où nous sommes
mettre d'autres choses dans la tête
[Musique]
si quelqu'un se risquerait à enquêter
bien bien ce qui existe dans ce lac je
Je pense que ce serait une surprise
Je ne dis pas que tu trouveras un prix
pas de balaou mais tu peux en trouver
bavard qui peut démystifier dans
à un moment donné le mythe du grand-père
Non, je n'ai pas vu mon grand-père
croire est de lire mon amour
est dans l'enquête en contact
avec les gens d'avoir vu d'avoir
quitté et lu à partir de Rechercher des informations
J'ai toujours été intéressé par tout ce type
des mystères et des énigmes n'est pas à partir de maintenant
j'ai été dans le
rechercher toutes ces sortes de choses
des ovnis parapsychologie de l'occultisme
cryptologie tout ce qui a un mot
Mystère j'aime donc je vais
J'enquête j'essaie de trouver le oui et le non
le Pourquoi et le Pourquoi ne pas dire non non
Je suis un fan disons que je suis un
personne qui a un critère
Je ne dis pas à tout que tout est un
possibilité spectaculaire qu'il puisse
être maintenant que je vous assure de
que ce soit, je ne sais pas, mais le
la possibilité est
non je ne perds pas vraiment mon temps avec
des théories qui n'ont rien à voir
l'investigation
Je les ai comme référence pour
dis Eh bien si quelqu'un me demande quoi
qu'en est-il du sceptique bien le sceptique
est-ce ceci ceci et cela et qu'en est-il
le vrai bien le vrai c'est ce qu'il voit
être témoin de ce qui est réel, c'est ce qu'ils vous disent
Ils sont réels, la photo est belle.
ils peuvent toucher la photo parce que c'est
très très courant aujourd'hui mais il y a des photos et
photographies Maintenant, il existe des techniques qui
ils disent bien cette photo est choquante et
celui-ci n'est pas et beaucoup de photographies qui
ils ont pris ne sont pas trompés parce qu'ils ont
fait toute l'analyse alors ils ont
vrais résultats et avec les théories
tu es prêt
de ce que sont les Bulles de ce qu'elles sont
Je les prends comme référence mais je ne le fais pas
Je prends comme une chose comme une chose même
réel
nous avons un petit bug qui ressemble à ça
petit, c'est quoi le cafard il y a 400 ans
millions d'années qui est sur le
La Terre et ces animaux mutaient en
oui ils mutaient mutant jusqu'à leur arrivée
à ce jour, pourquoi n'aurait-il pas pu y avoir
a muté un prix saurien pour atteindre
cette hauteur à cette vie à cette époque
pourrait tout aussi bien avoir
Je ne peux pas garantir qu'il l'a fait
mais si nous nous basons sur ces tests
énergiques qu'ils sont, vous ne pouvez pas dire
non parce que oui
[Musique]
touristes qui arrivent à San Carlos de
Bariloche vient essentiellement chercher
profiter de la nature cette région
a
nombreuses possibilités pour profiter de la
la nature non plus
en été avec le à la montagne
avec ses lacs
Un poète l'appela un jour au
région des quatre cieux parce qu'ils sont
bien différencié les quatre saisons
de l'année maintenant au printemps le
possibilité est de profiter de la première
journées ensoleillées avec 20 22 24 degrés de
température
permettre des activités de plein air
être libre à la fois dans les montagnes et dans
les lacs ou dans les rivières ou dans la steppe
Quelle est cette zone où la forêt n'est pas?
Je dis toujours que ce film va
changer
un peu d'histoire de la ville
la partie scientifique peut étayer tout
leurs paroles et la part des voisins et
les personnes qui ont eu une observation
peut également justifier et nous
nous pouvons connaître en profondeur et revivre
des récréations qui
d'observations et trouver
peut être
une réponse qui jusqu'à présent n'a pas donné
Pas de travail
début du 21ème siècle la présence de
mon grand-père dans toutes les excursions
c'était pratiquement tous les jours que tu le voyais
surtout les jours de printemps et
été les jours où le lac est calme
C'est repassé C'est ce que les gens disent
c'est quand on le voit mieux
entrepreneurs du tourisme en général
les institutions différents dirigeants
Ils ne parlent pas de nahuelitos si le
société le voisin commun alors que
chose est très intéressante à sauver
manifestation
[Musique]
la dernière référence que j'avais dans le
2006 mais soi-disant de 2006 à
2013 Quelques années se sont écoulées et des observations
Il en aura vu beaucoup, je ne dirai pas non avant
maintenant 6 500 espèces sont apparues
totalement différent des animaux
inconnu Aujourd'hui encore, il y a des animaux
tu ne sais pas comment les classer
As-tu vu que chaque animal a son nom ?
les scientifiques ne le savent pas
mettre pour déterminer quel type de
animaux Eh bien aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup
immense de ces nouvelles espèces qui
encore dans les grands centres ne sais pas
peut classer
nous habitons
une planète presque inconnue le message
que pour moi tout cela a cette histoire
millénaire c'est prenons soin de la nature
dis sois prudent avec le lac qui est
très mignon mais tu peux te noyer
essayer de
caresse et respecte beaucoup le lac
Los Arroyos un peu plus au sud sont les
glace continentale C'est la
interprétation que je fais ces
animaux avec des pièces femmes
Ce sont des animaux qui viennent déjà d'un
tradition
Parce que si nous parlons ou parlons de
sasquatch par exemple grosse peau los
Indiens d'Amérique du Nord les Chech
navajos tous ces anasasi déjà
Ils parlaient de toutes ces sortes d'êtres qui
vécu à cet endroit alors il vient de
une tradition et vous ne pouvez pas être pour
moi ça ne peut pas être que toutes les cultures
de ces personnes
vous avez vu toutes ces choses et non
existent, les êtres humains ont besoin de croire en
quelque chose en quoi l'être humain doit croire
quelque chose croit en Dieu croit en le
ces étrangers là-bas, nous pourrions
nous aurions une autre conversation est plus
faisable et nous devons croire en quelque chose et
Eh bien, nous croyons en un grand-père et pourquoi
Non
[Musique]